Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Is that really loud?
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Too quiet now.
Louder!
Like this!
BAU BAU!
One more time, okay?
Okay.
Moco-chan, can we do the thing where we jump out again?
Oh, okay.
One second.
Okay.
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Are you sure it's not too loud?
No!
I love his ears dying.
BAU BAU!
High five!
Well, hopefully it's good now.
Well, now that we're not destroying the Ruffians.
Ruffians!
Today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 113th episode!
We're not super loud today!
You never know what's gonna happen.
It's a lovely day and we got more fans!
BAU BAU!
For Ruffians who are joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face,
I hope you start your day off on the right paw.
Tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Yeah, it's short format.
Thank you.
It is!
I will show you how short it is.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
It just started!
Today's FUWAMOCO Morning just started, but the week is coming to a close, right?
But that doesn't mean that the fun is over!
No!
And how are we gonna have fun this weekend, Moco-chan?
We're gonna start with
Pero Sighting.
That's not fun though.
Is that fun, Ruffians?
I'm asking seriously right now.
No.
The Ruffians say no.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yes, it's surprising.
Yes, it's fun.
Nuh-uh.
Well, let's hear it here this time!
Okay.
De-den.
De-den!
I don't know, Ruffians.
Seems like Pero wasn't seen anywhere.
Ruffians.
Is this our fault?
Well, we're safe today.
Well, that's good.
You know, now we're into our second year here at hololive.
Maybe... Maybe this is a year without Pero.
I don't know.
Tell the truth.
I feel kinda sad, you know?
I don't know.
Feels a little bit...
It'll be okay.
We're strong demon guard dogs, right, Moco-chan?
We are the BAU BAU team by ourselves!
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Let's not think about those things.
Yeah, no.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO for you!
Yeah, like I mentioned, we are now officially into our second year here in hololive!
Because just the other day, we celebrated our first anniversary!
BAU BAU!
It was big, huh?
I don't know, you know what?
I'm just so happy to be able to celebrate it together with you.
Already one year has gone by.
I don't know, it still doesn't really connect.
I feel like every day I'm like, how?
How am I so lucky, huh?
Right.
But I think now, now that we've been at hololive for one year, I think now we're starting to feel... I remember hololive.
Me too.
Me too
I don't know.
The brain is gonna burst.
It's BAU BAU.
And BAU time hasn't helped yet either.
No.
But Ruffians, we really just can't wait for another year filled with precious memories.
Precious memories that we're able to make so precious because of you here with us, Ruffians.
Thank you!
We're gonna keep on protecting your smile!
But!
In case Ruffians, you know, there's a bunch of Ruffians I think a little bit busy.
Maybe you wanna know just what kind of exciting things we're up to in our first anniversary celebration!
Well, it wouldn't quite be FUWAMOCO without us singing a bunch of our favorite songs this time!
Special songs, you know, that we sung back when we
First debut!
But we did sing Sirens!
Sirens!
And of course we also looked over our debut as well!
That was something.
Nervous, FUWAMOCO.
Can you do an introduction?
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo.
Together we're FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
I think we're much, much more FUWAMOCO-y about being comfortable here with the FUWAMOCOs now.
Right!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, a little bit low-key, low-edgy.
Low-tension one.
Yeah.
But!
You know, we also revealed first anniversary merchandise!
Let's take a look, okay?
We have Icomochi-mama!
Icomochi-mama juice!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look, okay?
So this is the complete set of our first anniversary merch.
We have our Happy Puppy Happy, our BAU BAU Whiskey Chain Pero plushie, FUWAMOCO glass set, and the bonus.
Close up.
See?
Right here!
Wow, for the Ruffians, you know, some Ruffians are able to get their paws on the limited edition, which comes with a handwritten autograph of both myself, Moco-chan, too!
FUWAMOCO!
Together!
And for Ruffians, you know, so I want the complete set!
It comes with a duplicated foil stamp autograph as well.
Which is very, very nice to me.
Yeah, so you'll be able to display that, and you know...
How was that?
Yeah, here's our happy puppy!
Is this the first time you've seen a happy before?
It's definitely not the first time you've seen a happy puppy, huh?
Yeah, no, definitely not.
But a happy is something that you can wear at live performances and cheers or conventions, you know?
I know anyone will see you from like a mile away and be like, oh, that's a Ruffian, huh?
It's very, very cute, especially because of Icomochi-mama's illustration.
And you know, they're very particular about the designs.
Yes.
So please take a look at it.
It's gonna be very fluffy and fuzzy.
We wanna see all your happy looking!
We wanna see just how happy puppies you are, Ruffians, wearing the happy puppy outfit.
BAU BAU!
And next!
Yeah, the BAU BAU voice teacher!
With a super cute illustration by Reriko-san!
And there's six original voice recordings in it!
I wonder what it could be, huh?
But you can bring us with you everywhere!
Everywhere!
We'll protect your smile!
When you're feeling a bit like, uh, my BAU BAU voice is not good!
Just press it and it'll be there.
With the original voice.
The greetings!
They all have to find out what they are.
BAU BAU!
And next!
Nasty.
Ruffians, you really wanted a Pero plushie.
Here it is!
It's unfortunately terribly cute.
And it's life-size.
Pero life-size.
He'll be so perilous.
He's a bit bigger than the Ruffians, but, uh, yeah.
Unfortunately, I came out really, really cute.
He's round.
He's too cute.
I'm very cute.
Yeah.
One peron, yes.
So you want to make sure that you bring home your own peron pussy!
So that you can kick it and punch it and point it!
Do whatever you want with violent toys.
Violence.
Extreme violence.
Extreme violence!
So it's a cute peron pussy.
Yeah!
And next, we have the FUWAMOCO glass set!
You can drink two different types of drinks at the same time.
Yeah!
If you forgetful, or you know a glass and then Mocococo.
Water in one, tea in another.
Milk in one, orange juice in the other.
Maybe not that.
You won't get confused, right?
They're very different drinks.
Yeah!
Yeah, but you can drink from them while having a donut.
Yeah, we're watching us here.
So you know, first thing in the morning, you gotta have an ice coffee during FUWAMOCO Morning.
You can choose.
Oh, today it's gonna be the Fuwawa glass.
Maybe on the Wednesday, FUWAMOCO Morning, the Pup Talk, you drink out of the Moco-chan glass.
It's up to you!
And that's our anniversary!
We still on sale!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for getting your paws on the limited edition set!
We're so excited for you to be able to take a look at our signatures.
We're gonna put a lot of our hearts into them!
Thank you, Ruffians!
But that wasn't it!
That was a surprise.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
The most surprising, the most exciting thing happened!
FUWAMOCO!
We released our first original song!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
The song is titled, Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Ruffians, despite what you think, it's very nice and high quality.
This is not our 3D debut.
It's not our 3D debut.
Wait, they dance!
Yes, they dance!
With FUWAMOCO, of course they dance!
Please don't get confused, that is still yet to come.
But now Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★ is streaming on music platforms everywhere!
So you can listen to it wherever you want!
Please go and pick your favorite service, pick the place you listen to music.
Favorite it and listen, and listen, and listen, and listen.
Please, Ruffians!
And also, we had a bit of an afterparty for the rest.
Yeah, what did we do at the after party?
Yeah, there was a complete doggy boot camp.
Yeah, training session.
Yeah, and we taught all of Ruffians how to cheer the best way possibly for us.
Doing calls.
Yeah, you know, calls is something that they do at idol performances a lot.
And there's a lot of places where you can BAU BAU and FUWAMOCO.
Dang it.
So we wanted to do it all together with you Ruffians so that you'll be ready wherever you go.
And maybe like, uh... Now?
Now!
We'll do it now!
Let's do it once more right now, okay?
Okay, Ruffians!
I know it's first thing in the morning, but... Are you ready?
Are you ready?
Yeah, right now, right now!
Yeah.
Okay!
Okay, Ruffians!
Oh!
Here we go!
Okay, you ready?
Okay!
We're gonna BAU BAU right here.
BAU BAU!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO BAU BAU!
Clapping!
Doki Doki Doki!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU!
Clapping!
Clap!
Happy Doki Doki!
Oh!
Yattaiga coming up!
Ya!
Yattaiga!
Wahoo!
Come on!
Fuwa fuwa fuwa fuwa!
Hai!
Hai hai hai hai!
Moco!
BAU BAU!
Okay, here we BAU BAU!
Fuwa fuwa!
Mococo!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAWA!
MOCOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Ruffy!
Yuffie!
Oing again!
Oing!
Get the tigers ready!
Get the tigers ready
BAU!
BAU
New tiger coming up!
Unleash the tiger within you!
Yes!
Yes tiger!
Wahoo!
Come on!
Fuwa fuwa fuwa fuwa!
Hai!
Moto!
BAU BAU!
No BAU BAU!
Not yet!
To you!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Mococo!
BAU BAU!
Just like that!
That is how you BAU BAU to the max!
And Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★!
BAU BAU!
We hope you have a bunch of fun and that you'll be able to internalize it into your heart.
Yeah, I know it's all of a sudden first thing in the morning, but... But basically, you know, it's like a... What's it?
A radio exercise?
You know?
Right, right.
Punch to the left, punch to the right.
It's still not quite in your head yet, that's fine.
That's okay.
You just learned it, okay?
We're so happy Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I hope that you know, BAU DEM!
Not only will the calls be in your heart, but that the BAU BAU will be stuck in your brain forever and ever!
Yeah!
It's pretty catchy, you know?
You know, I'm actually sort of curious.
Oh?
I feel like it'd be cool to have a metal version.
A metal?
Yeah, a metal version.
FUWAMOCO!
Like that?
Yeah.
Oh.
Maybe the Ruffians have to take care of that!
Heck yeah!
How does the heck time become like sweet time?
I don't know.
That's something that maybe you can think of, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Please listen to Bunch of My Senpai!
Lots and lots of camoflague!
BAU BAU!
With all that excitement, there's also been something exciting going on too!
Lots of us hololive members, we're a part of HoloARC!
We're playing a game called ARC.
You know, with the dinosaurs, and the dinosaurs, and more dinosaurs.
Together with a bunch of my senpai in a huge event!
Members from JP, members from EN, like us, Karina-chan.
Yeah, me too.
It was so much fun!
We got to have our dinosaurs, and then we did big raids all together.
Yeah, but on the very last day, the final day, we fought a new dinosaur.
It's not a dinosaur, really.
It's a snowy owl.
Dinosaur.
It's a funny story.
It's very cute.
I guess it's a dinosaur.
We were part of the healing team, which is us and Hiroha-senpai.
Hiroha-senpai was an amazing, amazing leader for it.
We were able to heal both Jumai-senpai!
We did well and we beat the final raid too, even though it was a bit tough.
It was really scary.
Really silly.
I was like, oh, it's done.
No, it's not.
Suddenly, right before the radio, the dinosaurs are busy taking a bath.
They're still having dinner.
What's with that?
Huh?
Here I am waiting.
Waiting!
Because we got to talk with Yuruha-senpai a bunch about our favorite ice creams and tea ceremony and a bunch of silly things.
But we were just so happy because even though it was a pretty tricky game, we were complete beginners in everything.
We were just so happy to be able to get to know our senpai more.
We were able to get closer and bond and everything.
You know, that wasn't cool.
The dinosaurs are cute, but our senpai were cuter.
But next time, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Our dinosaurs.
We should get them with our own paws, you know?
Oh, I don't know how!
They were given to us by our senpai.
Yeah.
They're like, oh, I have something cute.
Give it to FUWAMOCO, you know?
Yeah.
I'm happy, but... I appreciate it.
We need to show that, you know, we're independent demon dolls.
Yeah.
We're self-sufficient, right?
Hand-me-downs.
No, they weren't hand-me-downs.
They were presents, okay?
Precious, precious presents, yeah.
But I really hope that we can play a game together again soon.
It was really fun.
You know, just like the spelling bee was.
I hope we can do more big collabs soon!
BAU BAU!
Thank you to Pekora-senpai and to all the staff that helped organize it.
Thank you, thank you!
BAU BAU!
And well, you know what?
That was one thing that we did in summer here that was very fun.
But the summer still continues!
It's still young!
And to continue the funness of summer, not just the summer of Advent, but hololive city has now started!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, do you remember hololive City?
We talked about it briefly before, but maybe it's a bit hard to remember.
A few months ago we talked about it.
hololive City is basically hololive teaming up together with a bunch of theme parks all across Japan.
Greetings, hololive city.
This is an amazing collab!
And this time, FUWAMOCO, we're part of hololive city and we're representing hololive at Tokyo Dome City Attraction!
Look at all our senpai!
Amazing!
FUWAMOCO
We're just so happy because we've seen a bunch of Ruffians, you know, having fun running around Tokyo Dome City, eating our shaved ice.
Yeah, the FUWAMOCO shaved ice!
And BAU BAU donuts!
Yeah, we have BAU BAU donuts!
They're super cute!
And actually, you know, we've seen some Ruffians be like, I wanted to get the donuts, but...
I wasn't able to get my paws on them.
They sold out.
I'm sorry.
But the shaved ice is very fluffy, very fuzzy, so we recommend that too.
But, you know, that's not just the Ruffians.
There's actually more Ruffians saying that, oh, I can't get my paws on FUWAMOCO's merchandise.
Somehow, some of our merch is already sold out despite it being the second day of the event.
Why are our acrylic stands going high?
Thank you, Ruffians!
We're really sorry!
We're really sorry, Ruffians, for couldn't get done.
Yeah, we really hope that there's a restock soon.
And also, a lot more Ruffians can get their paws on us too!
And then we can travel all together around Tokyo Dome City attractions!
It's gonna be fun.
Also make sure that you go on our rides of Hoppin' Droppin'.
It's not a kid's ride.
Droppin' is scary.
It's serious, okay?
And on that way, you can also hear us BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
While you ride it.
And maybe some music as well.
Huh?
Lots and lots of fun secrets!
If you're visiting Tokyo, please come on by!
The hololive city is going to be here until September, so hopefully you know if you have a fun summer trip coming up, you can stop on by!
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited.
I want to see even more photos of FUWAMOCO!
Yeah, I'm looking forward to it!
Would you ride that ride?
Yes!
Of course!
Hoppin' droppin'.
FUWAMOCO would ride that ride.
You can't just leave droppin' like that.
No!
He's hoppin'.
You have to be hoppin' too!
Yeah.
Hop on to droppin'.
But, speaking of hoppin', I'm kinda hoppin' down.
Excitement and nervousness, because... Advent's 3D debut is...
Can you believe it?
Ruffians, tonight... Tonight is a big day, but you know, it's just a few days after our first anniversary, right?
Yeah.
And Advent's 3D debuts are really soon!
In fact, you know, Biboo, her 3D debut is two days away.
Two days.
But, two days, I... It's hard to believe.
What's even less?
Even closer!
Shiori's debut!
That's tonight, Ruffians!
It's not even 24 hours away, that's tonight!
Is it 12 hours away?
I don't even know anymore.
Ruffians, are you hyped?
Are you excited?
I am discombobulated.
It's 11 hours from now.
Okay, it's not even 12!
Oh my gosh.
I don't know, Ruffians.
Let's get ready to see Shiori in her fully 3D body!
And see her being all silly, being all squally.
There, there.
Whatever other silly Shiori things she says, I don't like it either.
There'll be lots of them!
What time is that at?
It's at 8pm PT!
Or 12pm JST.
Make sure you get lots of snacks!
Shiori's favorite snacks... Shiori's really liked plonder rings recently.
Shiori, FUWAMOCO, can we get plonder rings?
Yes, Shiori, we can.
Yes, yes, yes!
It's at 8pm PT.
I don't think we can get even more hyped than that.
No.
It's gonna be busy.
Please get ready, Ruffians!
Let's all cheer on Shiori, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
I'm so, so excited.
I can't even believe it.
It's 4am for you.
I know it's tough, but...
3D debut though.
It only happened once.
3D debut only happens once.
Ruffians, Yuzu will never tell you to stay up the crazy hours.
But I think 3D debuts.
I think it's worth it.
I told somebody we very deeply love Shiori!
Biboo!
It's a special special event.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day today.
I feel like I need to see a doggy.
And this is the Doggie of the Day.
We have... De-den!
Bomi's a Doggie of the Day!
Bomi's a bundle of... I'm not feeling great though.
Get better soon, Bomi!
Get better!
I'm sure you know Bomi will be back to BAU BAUing.
I always feel better after being all bundled up.
Bundled up getting sick of these.
Then you'll be all ready to go again.
Bomi looks so nice and fluffy there, too.
Good eyebrows, huh?
Ten out of ten, dog!
Actually, you're mistaken.
Better than that.
A thousand out of ten.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, how does Bomi BAU BAU?
I think Bomi is probably feeling a little bit down, so maybe like... BAU BAU.
Very quiet.
Soon, Bomi will be like BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to hearing that BOOMY BAU BAU!
BOOMY!
BOOMY is just such a sweet and jolly little purr-purr!
And we hope you'll be back to full BOOMY level soon!
BOOMY STRENGTH!
Yeah!
We hope you can run around outside in the spring cleaning this summer time here!
Why do you feel so good?
Then, well, you may mistake.
You'll be a fully soggy doggy now.
BAU BAU!
See you very soon!
Well, thanks for our Today I Went On A Walk!
We have... De-den!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But, uh, the bees!
The bees!
I'm sure the bees are a little scary, but they're probably just doing a very important job, right?
Yeah, they're just buzz-buzzing around, huh?
Yeah, buzz-buzz.
Buzz-buzz.
They get close to you, just go BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
That's it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but good job for you getting out there to enjoy the lushness around the summer nature!
Yeah!
And weather!
And hopefully you had sunscreen on!
Yeah.
So do it next time for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
BAU BAU!
Bees are cute.
They are!
They're fuzzy, right?
They're fuzzy, but then they get a bit cold sometimes.
Yeah, and then they're like, ahh.
That's when you have to BAU BAU.
BAU BAU, run away.
But yeah.
But next, we have our Question of the Day!
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Does Mococo like Mango-chan?
Both the nicknames and the condiments.
Mangoes!
Mangoes are yummy!
I like mangoes!
It wasn't asked of me, but I like mangoes!
What about mango-chan, Moco-chan?
They yummy.
But fresh mangoes are better, right?
I like mangoes.
But Ruffians... You know, I'm Mococo, right?
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Mococo or Moco-chan is okay.
But I want people to know my name properly, okay?
If you change it too much...
It's not recognizable, you know?
That makes me a little bit sad.
Understood.
Got it.
Okay.
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
Okay.
What's the spell, Moco-chan?
What is the spell?
Mococo!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Please, we're always looking for your submissions.
We're looking closely.
Please send us your doggy of the days, your walks.
I know you're seeing beautiful things outside.
Please take a photo for us to see too, okay?
Your questions and your Pero Sightings, we haven't seen Pero recently, so please let us know.
BAU BAU!
Don't forget the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
For our next stream coming up, we have De-den!
It's Super Chat Week!
Thank you, Ruffians, for being here!
We're gonna read a bunch of your Super Chats and chat all about, you know, our recent feelings with our song release and our future anniversary and lots of stuff!
3D coming up!
So we hope you'll be there for a comfy time.
Just you be there, okay?
And then after that,
Wow, if you look at our schedule, Moco-chan, there's something big right after that!
Right after!
Shiori's 3D debut!
Yeah!
Mama!
We can't wait, so make sure you get nice and cozy for the super chat meeting, and then get ready for something else in Shiori's 3D debut!
That's what she has for us, huh?
But, don't forget the next day at the same time, Biboo's 3D debut is happening too, so...
Let's have a bunch of excitement!
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians who are joining us today through the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's BAU BAU!
Shiori, Biboo, Didi!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so so much Ruffians for joining us today and this week for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's time that we see you again for the next FUWAMOCO Morning!
Shiori and Biboo will both have made their CD debut!
That's crazy!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Zura!
BAU BAU!
Asherot!
Skytoot!
BAU BAU!
Socks Heroine!
Blue Soft Puppet.
BAU BAU!
Balnus.
Ellipsis.
BAU BAU!
Icy Nightheart.
Andy L. BAU BAU!
Pegasus Lee.
BAU BAU!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!